the era from 1945 to 1980 was
action-packed to say the least during
this period the United States
experienced the baby boom the civil
rights movement the tumultuous 1960s and
the quagmire of Vietnam this era was
also riddled with contradictions a sense
of optimism in the future and a
conviction that American economic
prosperity was endless was tempered by
fears of nuclear annihilation and a war
on poverty a foreign policy based on
democracy and anti-communism abroad was
undermined by the suppression of civil
rights and civil liberties at home
material comforts and Leave It to Beaver
visions of suburbia clashed with growing
calls for young people to tune in turn
on and drop out with the generation that
fought World War two even recognize the
generation that protested Vietnam that's
the question I'd like to explore in this
video taking a high-level look at the
impact the events of the post-war era
had on reshaping American national
identity
how much did American national identity
change and how much did it stay the same
over this time period to answer this
question first we have to define what we
mean by American national identity in
other videos we've looked at a few
aspects of American identity as core
ideological beliefs about things like
who counts as an American whether the
United States is exceptional or whether
it's possible for anyone to succeed so
long as they work hard enough so if
we're trying to track continuity and
change in American identity over the
period from 1945 to 1980 well it might
be a few beliefs we should trace over
time encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can come up with a couple
based on your knowledge of the events in
this time period some big events that
jump out to me are the Cold War and the
civil rights movement as well as the
protests of the 1960s so with that in
mind the core beliefs I'd like to look
at our ideas about the United States as
role in the world who counts as an
American citizen and the country's
cultural values you might have come up
with a totally different set of beliefs
which is great try out this same process
I'm about to
model using the beliefs that you've
chosen now that we've got a few aspects
of national identity we want to track
let's compare each of them at the
beginning of this period to the end of
this period remember we're doing a super
high level overview here so I'm not
gonna take a whole lot of time to
explain events in detail but if
something comes up that you're
unfamiliar with just make a note and you
can look it up when you've got time all
right let's see what changed and what
stayed the same over this period in
beliefs about the United States as role
in the world in 1945 the United States
emerged as a world superpower having
abandoned isolationism as a foreign
policy instead the United States became
a leading member of the United Nations
and the NATO defensive pact the US
government was determined to contain the
spread of communism and the influence of
the Soviet Union through providing
military and financial support to
nations fighting communism which would
lead to American military engagements in
Korea and Vietnam the United States also
had a lot of confidence in its economic
role in the world as the only country
whose industrial night hadn't been
compromised by World War two bombings
immediately after the war the United
States was the world's leading exporter
of steel cars
consumer goods and oil how does that
compare to beliefs about America's
proper role in the world in 1980 well
the United States was still a world
superpower at the end of this era and it
was still pursuing anti-communism as a
foreign policy but in the 1970s the Cold
War entered a period of day tante
a relaxation of tensions and increase in
cooperation between the United States
and the Soviet Union you could see this
as the US government accepting peaceful
coexistence with the Soviet Union this
approach will change when Ronald Reagan
comes into office in 1981 but the period
of date on lasted until the end of the
1970s the Vietnam War shook American
confidence in its interventionist
foreign policy after the war there was
more reluctance to commit US troops
abroad in what's been called Vietnam
syndrome likewise the Nixon doctrine
called for US allies to take primary
responsibility for their own defense
lastly US economic
world dominance was threatened in the
late 1970s as well as Japanese and
German automobile makers began competing
internationally and the energy-dependent
united states found that its energy
needs were increasingly tied to the oil
exporting countries of the Middle East
so in terms of what changed and what
stayed the same from the beginning to
the end of the post-war era I would say
that although the United States remained
a world superpower committed to
supporting its allies and opposing the
spread of communism at the end of the
1970s the country looked to establish
some limits to its intervention in world
affairs next let's look at how beliefs
about citizenship changed during this
period after the shared experience of
GIS in world war ii european immigrants
who had been looked upon as dangerous
others in the 1920s and 1930s were
accepted as US citizens and categorized
as simply white not polish or Irish or
Russian but African American soldiers
who had served in segregated units
during the war weren't afforded the same
courtesy despite Truman's executive
order desegregating the military in 1948
black veterans encountered racial
discrimination after the war along with
difficulty accessing the government
subsidies for education and home loans
that white GIS took advantage of the
immigration restrictions that set
national origin quotas in the 1920s were
still largely intact although the
Chinese Exclusion Act had been repealed
during the war as China was a US ally
Chinese Americans were then eligible to
become US citizens however the new quota
for Chinese immigrants was just 105
individuals per year what were the
beliefs around citizenship at the end of
the post-war era a lot changed during
this time period thanks to the civil
rights movement Supreme Court decisions
like Brown versus Board of Education and
legislation like the Civil Rights Act of
1964 and the Voting Rights Act of 1965
at the end of the 60s African Americans
were able to access more citizenship
rights than they ever had before and in
1965 Congress repealed the old national
origin quotas and passed new immigration
laws allowing Asians to enter the
country
as well as prioritizing family
reunification and the entrance of
skilled immigrants but in the late 1960s
and 1970s there was a backlash against
the civil rights policies set by the
Supreme Court and the Johnson
administration with many conservatives
arguing that the federal intervention to
advance civil rights had gone too far
and with some left-leaning organizations
arguing that it hadn't gone far enough
to address issues like housing and job
discrimination looking at the changes
and continuities and beliefs about
citizenship over this period I'd say
there was an enormous expansion over
time and who was considered a citizen or
eligible to become a citizen of the
United States but there was also a
growing antagonism toward the federal
government intervening on behalf of
civil rights last let's look at American
cultural values at the beginning and end
of the post-war era in the years after
the war there was an emphasis on
domesticity and family life and women
were expected to give up their wartime
jobs and seek fulfillment through
motherhood and consumption the United
States began a post-war economic boom
that looked virtually unstoppable in
fact the American standard of living
doubled in the 25 years after World War
Two there was also a lot of pressure for
Americans to conform to a homogeneous
mass culture ideal izing the white
suburban nuclear family fear of
communist infiltrators led to witch
hunts like McCarthyism but few people
question the wisdom of the US government
or authority figures in general compare
that to the end of this period after the
tumult of the 1960's had turned American
culture on its head in the 1960s and
1970s the sexual revolution and women's
rights movement challenged the idealized
nuclear family allowing for a more
permissive sexual culture and the
advancement of women in jobs and
education starting as early as the 1950s
The Beat Generation began to question
the emptiness of the single-minded
pursuit of wealth that was the American
dream in the 1960s students began to
protest the draft and the
military-industrial complex more
generally wondering what the United
States was even doing in Vietnam they
vowed not
trust anyone over 30 by the 1970s public
confidence in the US government was also
at an all-time low after revelations
about presidential misdeeds exposed by
the Pentagon Papers and the Watergate
scandal to add insult to injury the
endless economic boom finally seemed to
be at an end by the 1970s with
deindustrialization and stagflation
increasing prices and unemployment so it
seems like American cultural values
changed a great deal from 1945 to 1980
from a culture of suburban conformity to
one of greater personal freedom but also
greater cynicism but it is important to
note that the people of the United
States didn't fully reject the premise
of the American dream
despite the counterculture of the 1960s
by the 1970s most people were still
looking for a good job and hoping to buy
a nice home if we return to our question
then how much did the events of the
post-war era reshape American identity I
think we can respond that they reshaped
it quite a bit the civil rights movement
the Vietnam War and the protest
movements of the 1960s led to a u.s.
national identity that was considerably
more inclusive and socially free but
also a good deal less confident about
its government or its role in the world
to see how these forces played out in
the next stage of US history we'll have
to look to the 1980s